You may remember last fall President Obama decided to do something that lots of other presidents had done before. Him Give a short speech to the country's school kids at the start of the academic year. The head of the Republican Party in Florida, a man named Jim Grier, issued a statement saying that he was appalled that President Obama would be spreading his lies and socialist ideology to school children. Others chimed in. It kicked off a little fire storm in the media.
你可能还记得去年秋天，奥巴马总统决定做一件许多前任总统都做过的事。他在学年开始时对全国的学童发表了一场简短的演讲。佛罗里达州共和党负责人吉姆·格里尔（Jim Grier）发表声明称，他对奥巴马总统向学童散布谎言和社会主义意识形态感到震惊。其他人也随声附和。这在媒体中引发了一场小小的风暴。
--he joins us right now. Mr. Grier, thanks for coming on. You had put out a pretty strong statement the other day. You said the President-- you referred to him as the Pied Piper Obama. Pied Piper is a guy who took children away and they were never seen again. Is that what you think? I mean, really.
——他现在加入了我们的节目。格里尔先生，感谢你来到这里。你前几天发表了一份相当强硬的声明。你提到总统时称他为“吹笛人奥巴马”。吹笛人是一个把孩子们带走后就再也没有人见过的人。你是这么认为的吗？我是说，真的吗？
Well I don't want him to take children away, but I don't want to him to take their minds away either to push his agenda.
嗯，我不想让他把孩子们带走，但我也不希望他为了推行自己的议程而带走他们的思想。
When the President finally gave his speech, what was his socialist message for the nation's school children? Put down the video games, read books, come to class ready to work hard.
当总统最终发表演讲时，他给全国学童的社会主义信息是什么呢？放下电子游戏，阅读书籍，准备好在课堂上努力学习。
--and along those lines, by the way, I hope all of you are washing your hands a lot, and that you stay home from school when you don't feel well so we can keep people from getting the flu this fall and winter.
——顺便提一下，我希望你们所有人都要勤洗手，如果感觉不舒服就待在家里不去学校，这样我们就能防止人们在今年秋冬感染流感。
After the speech, the controversy pretty much vanished overnight, and for most of us, that's the last we heard of Jim Grier, the guy who led the complaining. During the last year, a lot has changed for Jim Grier.
演讲结束后，争议几乎一夜之间消失了，对我们大多数人来说，这就是我们最后一次听到吉姆·格里尔——那个带头抱怨的人——的消息。在过去的一年里，吉姆·格里尔发生了很大的变化。
James A. Grier has been charged with six felony counts--
詹姆斯·A·格里尔已被控六项重罪——
He's no longer the Chairman of the Florida Republican Party. He's currently facing a half dozen felony counts for things like money laundering and theft. And two weeks ago, Grier did something kind of remarkable. With the school year starting again, all of a sudden he essentially came out of hiding to send a single message: a text message.
他不再是佛罗里达州共和党主席。他目前因洗钱和盗窃等罪名面临六项重罪指控。两周前，格里尔做了一件相当引人注目的事情。随着新学年的开始，他突然从隐身状态中走出来，发送了一条信息：一条短信。
It was September 14, actually. Grier sent a text message to reporters in Florida.
事实上是在9月14日。格里尔给佛罗里达州的记者发了一条短信。
A couple of days ago, I sat down with one of the reporters who first wrote about the story, Dave Weigel, who's a political reporter for Slate.
几天前，我采访了最早报道这个故事的记者之一，戴夫·魏格尔（Dave Weigel），他是《Slate》杂志的政治记者。
And the text messages say that, well the President's going to be giving another speech. And just for the record, I apologize for making such a big deal about the last one. My take on that was, wow, he admitted it. This was somebody being honest about the fact that this was not really something he had been worried about at the time. It was a pander to get people panicked to basically support the Republican Party. He just wanted, for whatever reason, to have a mea culpa. And you never really get a mea culpa after people have started a frenzy about something they know was not really a problem.
短信里说，总统要发表另一场演讲。声明一下，对于之前小题大作，我表示道歉。我的看法是，哇，他承认了。这表现出有人诚实地承认，这并不是他当时真正担心的事情。这只是一种为了让人们恐慌从而支持共和党的讨好行为。无论出于什么原因，他只是想做一个“负荆请罪”的姿态。在人们对一个他们明明知道不是真正问题的事情引发狂热之后，你永远不会真正得到“负荆请罪”。
That's especially true today, Weigel says. When manufactured outrage has become such a big part of our politics.
魏格尔说，这一点在今天尤其适用。当人为制造的愤怒已经成为我们政治中如此重要的一部分时。
Oh, this happens about once a week now. You can't quite set your watch to it, but you can expect on a Monday that by Friday, something that wasn't actually a huge problem for some politician or political figure is going to be blown up into a huge problem. They're going to benefit. We're going to have to analyze it.
哦，这现在每周发生一次。你不能完全以此作为准确的时间表，但你可以预料到，周一发生的事情，到周五就会被某些政客或政治人物炒作成一个巨大的问题。他们会从中受益。我们不得不对此进行分析。
Both parties do this, but Weigel says it's a much bigger part of Republican political style right now. And frankly, the Republicans are just a lot better at it.
两个党派都这样做，但魏格尔说，这在目前的共和党政治风格中占了更大的比重。坦率地说，共和党人在这方面确实要高明得多。
I mean, attack's really been part of Democrats' strategy this year that's been pretty unsuccessful-- is they continually think they're going to get sympathy from their base if Republicans are seen to be overly mean and blocking something in the Senate. That hasn't worked.
我的意思是，攻击实际上是民主党今年策略的一部分，但非常不成功——他们不断地认为，如果共和党人被视为过于卑鄙并阻挠参议院的事务，他们就会从选民基础中获得同情。这没有奏效。
So the Democrats try to rouse the troops without rage of the Republicans saying no, and it doesn't seem to change the political equation very much at all. The Republicans meanwhile are not only better at attacking. When they're attacked, they do a better job flipping the script and turning the story into outrage over the unfairness of how they were attacked, turning that into support and money. The example of this on our TVs this week, of course, is Delaware Senatorial candidate Christine O'Donnell. Even before the statements that she made about dabbling in witchcraft came to light, she was questioned about how she handled campaign finances, about people who didn't get paid, about a campaign worker who said that O'Donnell used contributions to cover rent and personal expenses.
所以民主党人试图通过对共和党的拒绝感到愤怒来激励支持者，但这似乎根本没有改变政治格局。与此同时，共和党人不仅更擅长攻击。当他们受到攻击时，他们更善于扭转局势，将故事转化为对他们受到不公平对待的愤怒，进而将其转化为支持和资金。我们电视上本周的例子当然是特拉华州参议员候选人克里斯汀·奥唐奈（Christine O'Donnell）。甚至在关于她涉足巫术的言论曝光之前，她就因处理竞选财务、拖欠员工工资、以及一名竞选工作人员称奥唐奈挪用捐款支付房租和个人开支的问题而受到质疑。
We know, for example, in this campaign, her mother got a $3,000 check, and no one can really explain that. So if you look at this on paper and you analyze it, like you analyze any story of fiscal incompetence, you wouldn't think she could turn this to her advantage. She did turn it to her advantage. She won the primary, and she raised, in the first five days after it, about $2 million. And that, according to her in the campaign and people around her, is in large part a response to the way the media was covering her finances, the way the media was covering her career as a TV pundit.
我们知道，例如在这次竞选活动中，她母亲收到了一张3000美元的支票，没有人能真正解释这一点。所以，如果你从纸面上看，像分析任何财政无能的故事一样分析它，你不会认为她能将其转化为自己的优势。但她确实做到了。她赢得了初选，并在初选后的头五天里筹集了大约200万美元。据她和竞选团队以及身边的人说，这在很大程度上是对媒体报道她财务状况、以及媒体报道她作为电视评论员职业生涯的一种回应。
What are we to make of the attacks against you?
我们该如何看待针对你的攻击？
Well, watch this. Watch how this campaign unfolds. They started their ads this week, and they're attacking me personally. They're not attacking where I stand on stimulus, they're not attacking where I stand on extending, if not making permanent, the Bush tax cuts. They're not attacking me on my positions. They're trying to attack me.
嗯，看看这个。看看这次竞选是如何展开的。他们本周开始了他们的广告，他们在人身攻击我。他们没有攻击我在经济刺激方案上的立场，也没有攻击我在延长（如果不是永久化）布什减税政策上的立场。他们没有攻击我的立场。他们只是试图攻击我。
She was able to turn this back into proof that the media was trying to tear her down. It was not an outrage that she said it, it was an outrage that this was being brought up, drudged up against her. The way O'Donnell put it was that, this is attack on me, but-- and she said this, her supporters also said this more explicitly-- it's an attack on people who believe the way I believe. This is an attack on Christianity. It's an attack on our values. And the money she raised off that, which-- $2 million is actually 10,000% of what she had in her campaign fund before the campaign heated up, at the end of August.
她能够将这一切扭转为媒体试图摧毁她的证据。人们愤怒的不是她说的话，而是这些陈年旧事被翻出来针对她。奥唐奈的说法是，这是对我的攻击，但——她这么说了，她的支持者也更明确地表达了这一点——这是对和我持有相同信仰的人的攻击。这是对基督教的攻击。这是对我们价值观的攻击。她从中筹集的资金——200万美元实际上是她在8月底竞选升温之前竞选基金中所拥有资金的10000%——
Before the attacks.
在攻击之前。
Before the attacks, she had $20,000 roundabout, and then she got $2 million after this. The way she pivoted is just a great textbook example.
在攻击之前，她大约有2万美元，然后在这之后她得到了200万美元。她转换话题的方式是一个绝佳的教科书式例子。
Being outraged works. Playing the victim works, for that matter. And today on our radio show we see that not just in politics, but in sports, on Wall Street, on the streets of California. We also, by the way, have a brand new story by David Sedaris. We have victims, we have mock outrage, we have mark outrage that turns into real outrage, we have real outrage that's bigger than maybe it should be. We have crybabies of all sorts, but mostly very, very effective ones. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
愤怒是有用的。扮演受害者也同样有效。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们看到这不仅发生在政治领域，还发生在体育、华尔街和加利福尼亚街头。顺便说一下，我们还有戴维·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）的一篇全新故事。我们有受害者，我们有伪装的愤怒，我们有演变成真实愤怒的虚假愤怒，我们有比实际情况更严重的真实愤怒。我们有各种各样的“哭闹者”，但大多数都非常、非常有效。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是由国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One. Wall Street: Money Never Weeps. You'd think if anybody would be out there thanking President Obama for helping them out these past few years, it would be Wall Street. Back when he was running for office, Barack Obama led the Democrats in supporting President Bush's original bailout of Wall Street. And as President, he kept that bailout going, and put into place all kinds of regulatory measures to make it easier for banks to recover and to turn a profit. And he's paid the price with some voters for that. But no, Wall Street is not happy with him. At the President's televised town hall meeting this week, hedge fund manager and CNBC commentator Anthony Scaramucci told them this, to his face.
第一幕。华尔街：金钱从不哭泣。你可能会认为，如果过去几年有人应该感谢奥巴马总统对他们的帮助，那一定是华尔街。早在奥巴马竞选公职时，他就领导民主党支持布什总统最初对华尔街的救助。作为总统，他延续了这项救助，并实施了各种监管措施，使银行更容易恢复并盈利。他也因此而受到了一些选民的责难。但是不，华尔街对他并不满意。在本周总统的电视市政厅会议上，对冲基金经理兼CNBC评论员安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇（Anthony Scaramucci）当面告诉他：
I represent the Wall Street community. We have felt like a pinata. Maybe you don't feel like you're whacking us with a stick, but we certainly feel like we've been whacked with a stick.
我代表华尔街社区。我们感觉自己像个皮纳塔（彩罐）。也许你并不觉得你在用棍子打我们，但我们肯定觉得自己被狠狠地打了一顿。
Back during the summer-- kind of famously-- a billionaire named Stephen Schwarzman, who founded and runs a private equity firm called The Blackstone Group, went even further. At a meeting that he thought was private, Schwarzman declared that the President's proposal to raise the taxes on certain profits that his company makes from 15% to 35%-- 35% being the corporate income tax that most companies pay-- he said that tax change was just like Hitler invading Poland in 1939.
今年夏天——相当出名的一件事——一位名叫斯蒂芬·施瓦茨曼（Stephen Schwarzman）的亿万富翁，他创办并经营着一家名为黑石集团（The Blackstone Group）的私募股权公司，甚至走得更远。在一次他认为是私下的会议上，施瓦茨曼声称总统提议将他的公司从某些利润中征收的税率从15%提高到35%——35%是大多数公司缴纳的企业所得税——他说这种税收改革就像1939年希特勒入侵波兰一样。
Well, I think we all obviously agree with that view, that shifting the tax structure of private equity firms is-- I don't really see any difference between that and Hitler invading Poland. Yeah, I mean obviously we can just laugh at it, but Stephen Schwarzman and The Blackstone Group have spent the last two years or three years, since the crisis began, finding so many different government incentives, government programs, that allows them to directly profit from the government's overall effort to pump up the financial sector.
嗯，我想我们显然都同意那个观点，即改变私募股权公司的税收结构是——我真的看不出这和希特勒入侵波兰有什么区别。是的，我的意思是显然我们可以对此一笑置之，但斯蒂芬·施瓦茨曼和黑石集团在危机开始后的过去两三年里，找到了如此多不同的政府激励措施和政府项目，使他们能够直接从政府刺激金融业的整体努力中获利。
For example?
例如？
So one example is, he bought a bank from the FDIC, the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation, at x ridiculously discounted rates.
例如，他以极低的折扣率从FDIC（联邦存款保险公司）购买了一家银行。
Another?
还有一个例子？
Another is, he took advantage of a variety of government programs that allowed him to buy up these toxic assets you always hear about at really low prices with government guarantees, almost guaranteeing that he would make money. So yeah, he'll have to pay taxes. He's a billionaire, and he's made a lot of money, even during the crisis. But a good chunk of the money he's made is the direct result of what President Obama and his administration have done to help out Wall Street.
另一个是他利用了各种政府计划，这些计划允许他以极低的价格购买你经常听到的那些有毒资产，并有政府担保，几乎保证了他能赚钱。所以，是的，他必须纳税。他是个亿万富翁，即使在危机期间也赚了很多钱。但他赚到的大部分钱是奥巴马总统及其政府为帮助华尔街所做工作的直接结果。
And so how much whining and complaining are Wall Street guys doing about the federal government now? Like this guy, Stephen Schwarzman, is he an outlier?
那么华尔街的人现在对联邦政府有多少抱怨和不满？像这个人，斯蒂芬·施瓦茨曼，他是个特例吗？
My view is, he represents a much broader view, and he's one of a very few who have the guts and confidence to say that. It's something I have noticed. I cover Wall Street a lot. I talk to people who work on Wall Street-- high level people, lower level people-- a lot. And it's something that I have found sort of maddening. And if I can use an odious and ridiculous comparison, it reminds me a lot of Ba'athists in Iraq.
我的观点是，他代表了一种更广泛的观点，他是极少数有胆量和信心说出这一点的人之一。这是我注意到的一件事。我经常报道华尔街。我和在华尔街工作的人交谈——高层人士，底层人士——很多。这是我发现的一种令人抓狂的事情。如果我可以使用一个令人厌恶和荒谬的比较，它让我想起了伊拉克的复兴党人。
Ba'athists being Saddam Hussein's party. These are the people who made money, and were in power, when Saddam Hussein was running the country.
复兴党是萨达姆·侯赛因的党派。这些人是萨达姆·侯赛因统治国家时赚钱并掌握权力的人。
Yes, and I'm talking about high level Ba'athists that, when I when in Iraq after the war, the group that I found had the most self-pity, the most, ugh, how horrible my life is, nobody understands me, the world has just turned against me, were those people who had made a fortune through the evil and illegal activities of the Ba'athist regime that they were a part of. And it feels very similar when I'm talking to people on Wall Street-- this self-pity combined with a total lack of self-reflection about how they had been such massive beneficiaries of a system that ended up being so bad for the country.
是的，我说的是高层复兴党人，当我战后在伊拉克时，我发现这一群体表现出的自我怜悯最强，最觉得“哎呀，我的生活多么糟糕，没有人理解我，全世界都反对我”，正是那些通过他们所属的复兴党政权的邪恶和非法活动发家致富的人。当我与华尔街的人交谈时，感觉非常相似——这种自我怜悯与完全缺乏对自己如何成为一个最终对国家如此糟糕的系统的巨大受益者的反思结合在一起。
And that continues to generate huge profits.
而且这继续产生巨大的利润。
Yeah. Pretty much every big bank that you can name-- with the possible exception of maybe JPMorgan Chase-- would not exist today. It would have failed, if it wasn't for the government. They are growing quickly and making record profits, huge bonuses. By some counts, this year will be the biggest bonus year ever for Wall Street, and last year was bigger that any year before. So that bucket of activity-- let's just call it the bailout, although it covers more than the bailout-- most folks on Wall Street, who I know, feel that, well, that was just necessary. If we had gone down, the whole US economy, the whole world economy, would have gone down. We would have had a Great Depression. And I will say, I'm sympathetic to that argument. That being said, it still seems to me that it would be appropriate for folks on Wall Street to say publicly, and to really have inside of their souls, the fact that their businesses failed. And something that they have always said they're against, government intervention, rescued them, made them get the opposite of what you're supposed to get in a Capitalist economy-- rewarded, instead of punished, for bad risk management. And instead, I cannot think of a single thing I've heard in the media, or that I have directly heard, that expresses any gratitude and-- there's a few folks who I've heard-- self-reflection. But I'd say self-reflection is a very small, small percentage of what I hear from Wall Street.
是的。几乎你能叫出名字的每一家大银行——除了摩根大通（JPMorgan Chase）外——如果不是因为政府，今天都不会存在。它们本会倒闭。它们现在增长迅速，赚取创纪录的利润，发给巨额奖金。据一些人估计，今年将是华尔街有史以来奖金最高的一年，而去年已经比以往任何一年都高。所以那一块业务——我们姑且称之为救助，尽管它涵盖的范围比救助更广——我认识的大多数华尔街人认为，嗯，那是必要的。如果我们倒下了，整个美国经济，整个世界经济都会倒下。我们会经历大萧条。我会说，我同情那个论点。话虽如此，对我来说，华尔街的人们如果能在公开场合说出来，并且在内心深处真正意识到他们的业务其实是失败的，那会是合适的。而政府干预，即他们一直声称反对的东西，拯救了他们，使他们得到了本应在资本主义经济中得到的结果的对立面——奖励，而不是惩罚，因为糟糕的风险管理。相反，我无法想到我在媒体上听到的，或者我直接听到的任何一件表达感激的事情，以及——我听过极少数人——自我反思。但我会说，自我反思在华尔街的声音中只占极小极小的比例。
But wait. Isn't there some kind of pro forma, we're very grateful to the federal government for stepping in, sort of thing that big bankers have to say when they give speeches to the public?
但是等等。难道大银行家在向公众发表演讲时，没有一种形式上的“我们非常感谢联邦政府的介入”之类的说法吗？
I haven't heard that.
我没听说过。
What about when they go in front of Congress? Don't they'd say like, thanks, you saved us, we just want to acknowledge what's happened here in this partnership with the federal government, blah blah blah?
当他们去国会面前时呢？他们难道不应该说，谢谢，你们救了我们，我们只想承认这里发生的这种与联邦政府的伙伴关系，诸如此类？
I haven't watched every hearing, but I've watched a lot of them, maybe most of them. I can't think of a time that someone said my bank, that I run, would not exist today. It failed because we took actions that led to our investors and our lenders having no faith in us. But the government stepped in, and because of that, we are making more money than we've ever made before.
我没有看过每一次听证会，但我看过很多，也许是大部分。我想不出有哪一次有人说，我经营的银行今天不会存在。它失败了，因为我们采取的行动导致投资者和贷方对我们失去了信心。但是政府介入了，正因为如此，我们赚的钱比以往任何时候都多。
Yeah, what about if you go ahead and just talk to the work-a-day people who work on Wall Street? The analysts, the brokers, the traders, the middle level people who make a lot of money. Are they whining about the Obama administration? Are they grateful for the federal government, and all of us taxpayers, saving their asses?
是的，如果是直接去和在华尔街工作的普通人交流呢？分析师、经纪人、交易员，那些赚很多钱的中层人员。他们在抱怨奥巴马政府吗？他们感激联邦政府和我们所有纳税人救了他们吗？
See, this is a perfect example. Alex Blumberg, my partner in Planet Money, and I went out for a drink. And we were out, we went to a Wall Street bar. And there's this private dining room that had been rented by a group of young guys-- clearly Wall Street guys, suits and ties. And it was a group of furious Wall Street guys, getting together to figure out what to do about their anger at the President and the Democrats in Congress. And one of the guy said, I swear to God, they're trying to destroy business in America. And they were discussing, what should we do? How do we fight the President? How do we fight Congress? Should we get a march on Washington? Other people were saying, no, that's not going to work. And, I gotta say, it was a pretty emblematic moment. I'm willing to bet that you could go to just about any bar around Wall Street, any night of the week, and you will find someone complaining about the President, complaining about the government, and all the different ways they are hurting Wall Street.
看，这是一个完美的例子。《Planet Money》的合伙人亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我出去喝了一杯。我们去了一家华尔街酒吧。那里有一个私人餐厅，被一群年轻人租用了——很明显是华尔街的人，穿着西装打着领带。这是一群愤怒的华尔街人，聚在一起想办法应对他们对总统和国会民主党人的愤怒。其中一个人说，我发誓，他们试图摧毁美国的商业。他们在讨论，我们该怎么办？我们怎么反击总统？我们怎么反击国会？我们应该在华盛顿举行游行吗？其他人说，不，那不会奏效。我必须说，这是一个非常具有代表性的时刻。我敢打赌，你一周中的任何一个晚上去华尔街附近的任何酒吧，都会发现有人在抱怨总统，抱怨政府，以及所有他们伤害华尔街的方式。
And in fact, to test this theory, just last week you went with one of our producers, Jane Feltes, to a bar down on Wall Street. And you talked to just random guys who you walked up to at the bar.
事实上，为了测试这个理论，就在上周，你和我们的制片人之一简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）去了华尔街的一家酒吧。你和酒吧里随意走近的人交谈。
Yeah, exactly. The bar was called Pound & Pence. It's literally across the street from the Federal Reserve Bank of New York-- filled with guys talking about their options, hedging strategies, and their new software database for monitoring capital flows.
是的，完全正确。酒吧叫Pound & Pence。它就在纽约联邦储备银行的对面——里面挤满了谈论他们的期权、对冲策略以及他们用于监控资本流动的新软件数据库的人。
And you found these guys, and you recorded conversations. And these guys very much felt like they are the victims. They are being scapegoated by the federal government.
你找到了这些人，并录下了对话。这些人非常觉得自己是受害者。他们被联邦政府当成了替罪羊。
The government must, must, must have an enemy. Because if they don't have an enemy, they're the enemy. So Wall Street is the current enemy, OK?
政府必须、必须、必须有一个敌人。因为如果他们没有敌人，他们自己就是敌人。所以华尔街是当前的敌人，好吗？
So it was three guys, and it was actually kind of moving. It's right after September 11. They all worked together in, I think it was, the second tower of the World Trade Centers. On September 11, they're on the 58th floor, One guy was saying that he didn't want to leave the building. And the other guy told him he had to leave, so every year they have a drink. He buys his friend a drink for saving his life. They now all work for different companies, but they get together around September 11 every year.
所以那是三个人，实际上有点令人感动。那是9月11日之后不久。据我所知，他们都在世贸中心的第二座塔楼一起工作。在9月11日，他们在58楼。一个人说他不想离开大楼。另一个人告诉他必须离开，所以每年他们都会喝一杯。他为挽救朋友生命的朋友买单。他们现在都在不同的公司工作，但每年9月11日前后都会聚在一起。
Now, I've listened to this tape before. We walked into the studio, and we're just going to play snippets here. But it was interesting. It's interesting hearing it, how at no point will they cop to the notion that they benefited from the government's actions. Even once.
现在，我以前听过这段录音。我们走进录音棚，我们只打算在这里播放片段。但很有趣。听到这段录音很有趣，他们在任何时候都不承认他们从政府的行为中受益的观点。一次都没有。
You think everybody that works on Wall Street has money from the bailout? Is that what you really think?
你认为在华尔街工作的每个人都从救助中拿了钱吗？你是真的这么认为吗？
I think the reason Wall Street still exists, in this form today, where you're all sitting in a bar drinking beers--
我认为华尔街今天仍以这种形式存在的原因，就是你们所有人坐在酒吧里喝啤酒——
Now, I should say you guys are shouting not because you're angry, but because it's just really loud.
现在，我应该说你们大喊大叫不是因为愤怒，而是因为这地方确实太吵了。
Yeah, it was a really loud bar. It was packed. And we've been arguing with these guys. We've been going back and forth for quite awhile at this point.
是的，那是一个非常吵闹的酒吧。挤满了人。我们一直在和这些人争论。在这一点上我们已经来回争论了很久。
So you're an institutional investor, you work for a credit rating agency. What do you do?
所以你是机构投资者，你在信用评级机构工作。你是做什么的？
I work in a bank on Wall Street.
我在华尔街的一家银行工作。
All right. I can guarantee your bank would've gone under. Your stock valuation would've collapsed. Your credit rating agencies--
好了。我可以保证你的银行会倒闭。你的股票估值会崩盘。你的信用评级机构——
Are out of business.
会倒闭。
--would've been out of business. All three of you directly benefited from the bailout.
——会倒闭。你们三个都直接从救助中受益了。
What?
什么？
You're crazy!
你疯了！
How am I crazy?
我怎么疯了？
You're crazy, babe! So what do you do? Don't bail it out? That's the question. Do you not bail it out?
你疯了，宝贝！那么你该怎么办？不去救助吗？这就是问题所在。你选择不救助吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
OK. So you let it tank. It's up to you.
好吧。所以你让它倒掉。取决于你。
I would like to bail it out, and  I would like to walk into a bar in lower Manhattan, and have one of you thank me. Thank you, I still have my job and I appreciate it.
我希望救助它，我也希望走进曼哈顿下城的一家酒吧，你们中的一个人能感谢我。谢谢，我还有这份工作，我很感激。
Why do you want that?
你为什么想要那个？
You guys still have your jobs.
你们依然有工作。
Because I'm a smart person.
因为我是一个聪明人。
And you think you got to keep your job because you're smart? You got to keep your job because you guys got bailed out. You guys got bailed--
你认为你保住了工作是因为你聪明？你保住工作是因为你们得到了救助。你们得到了救助——
No, no, no, no, no. That's not what happened with my job. I mean, survival of the fittest.
不，不，不，不，不。我的工作不是那样发生的。我的意思是，优胜劣汰。
Because I'm smarter than the average person.
因为我比一般人聪明。
And even if the government bails out your industry that failed, you still say it's because you're smarter.
即使政府救助了你那失败的行业，你仍然说这是因为你更聪明。
No. The government bailing out an industry was out of necessity for whatever the situation was. The fact that I benefited from that is because I'm smart. I took advantage of a situation. 95% of the population doesn't have that common sense. The only reason I've been doing this for so long is because I must be smarter than the next guy.
不。政府救助一个行业是出于无论当时情况如何的必要。我从中受益的事实是因为我聪明。我利用了一个局势。95%的人口没有那种常识。我做这个做了这么久，唯一的原因是我肯定比别人更聪明。
They basically saw it as their own individual initiative is what put them where they are today, government had nothing to do about it.
他们基本上认为，是他们个人的主动性让他们处于今天的位置，政府与此毫无关系。
Yes. My thought is-- that for at least some folks on Wall Street-- you have to come up with a story that explains to you why you are making so much more than other people, even if you feel you are dramatically benefiting society. And I think the story they come up with is that they are battling in a true free market. That they are taking risky bets, and they are paying the cost when those bets don't pay off, and they're reaping the rewards when those bets do pay off. I don't think that can possibly be defended by a careful study of what has happened. I think it's quite the opposite. I think Wall Street firms took enormously risky bets, reaped whatever rewards there were to make, but did not have to pay the costs when those bets did not pay off. The rest of us did.
是的。我的想法是——对于至少一些华尔街的人来说——你必须编造一个故事来解释为什么你赚的钱比别人多得多，即使你觉得你对社会有巨大的贡献。我认为他们编造的故事是，他们在真正的自由市场中战斗。他们在进行冒险的赌博，当这些赌博没有回报时，他们承担成本，而当这些赌博有回报时，他们获得奖励。我不认为这可以通过对已经发生的事情的仔细研究来辩护。我认为恰恰相反。我认为华尔街公司进行了极其冒险的赌博，获得了任何可以获得的奖励，但在这些赌博没有回报时却不必承担成本。我们其他人承担了。
And do the Wall days have a legitimate beef? Is there something that Obama has done to them that they're right to get mad about?
华尔街的人有合理的抱怨吗？奥巴马对他们做的某件事让他们有权感到愤怒吗？
I think that there are two things that I see as, at least, somewhat legitimate. Yes. One thing that I'd say, sure, they have a right to be mad about-- in the sense that any of us would-- is they're going to make less money, probably. These regulatory reforms are going to come into place over the next two, three years. And we know that some of those were specifically designed to lessen profits for Wall Street banks. Capital reserve requirements-- the amount of money you have to hold on hand-- we know that capital reserve requirements are going to increase, and that directly means they'll make less money.
我认为我看到的有两件事，至少在某种程度上是合理的。是的。有一件事我想说，当然，他们有权感到愤怒——就我们任何人都会感到愤怒的意义上——是他们可能会赚更少的钱。这些监管改革将在未来两三年内实施。我们知道其中一些是专门为了减少华尔街银行的利润而设计的。资本储备金要求——你必须持有的资金数额——我们知道资本储备金要求将会增加，这直接意味着他们赚的钱会变少。
Because, basically, they have to hold more money on hand. So they can't either use that money as their profits or go out and invest that and make more money with.
因为，基本上，他们必须手头持有更多的现金。所以他们不能把这笔钱作为利润，或者出去投资赚更多的钱。
Right. There's a whole host of other things that the regulatory reform closes off that were avenues to profits. So yes, I think definitely-- it's almost indisputable-- that in the short term, regulatory reform will mean they will make less money than they would have otherwise. The second issue is vilification. I think if you work on Wall Street-- actually I can assert this 100%-- you feel vilified. And I think if you work within Wall Street, chances are you didn't work directly with subprime mortgages, and collateralized debt obligations, and derivatives, or any of the things that got the economy in trouble, or were central to the financial crisis.
对。监管改革还关闭了许多其他的利润渠道。所以是的，我认为绝对——几乎是无可争辩的——在短期内，监管改革将意味着他们赚的钱比原本会赚的要少。第二个问题是污名化。我想如果你在华尔街工作——事实上我可以100%确定这一点——你会感到被污名化。而且我认为如果你在华尔街内部工作，你很可能没有直接从事次级抵押贷款、担保债务凭证、衍生品，或者任何导致经济陷入麻烦或处于金融危机核心的事情。
I'm just thinking about your comparison to the Ba'athists in Iraq. Is it just it that these people who are in a position of such privilege will just whine more, because they're just used to being on top and getting their way?
我只是在想你对伊拉克复兴党人的比较。是因为这些处于如此特权地位的人会抱怨更多，因为他们只是习惯于高高在上并随心所欲？
Yeah. I spent a lot of time in Haiti this year, and I spent a lot of time with wealthy Haitians and with poor Haitians. And I would say the wealthy Haitians definitely went out for being more crybabyish. People don't understand us. People are getting in our way. The poor Haitians are literally the poorest people on earth, and it's not that I never heard complaining, but it wasn't nearly as much. I'd say I had a very similar experience in Banda Aceh after the tsunami. That has been my experience-- that the rich and the powerful, when there is a shock, are much more vocal and much more self-pitying than the poor. Maybe the poor are more used to these shocks. Maybe they have lower expectations about the future. But this Wall Street stuff didn't surprise me, although it is disappointing.
是的。我今年在海地花了很多时间，我和富有的海地人和贫穷的海地人相处了很多时间。我会说富有的海地人绝对更爱哭闹。人们不了解我们。人们在阻碍我们。贫穷的海地人实际上是地球上最贫穷的人，并不是说我从没听到过抱怨，但没有那么多。我想我在海啸后的班达亚齐也有非常相似的经历。这就是我的经验——当发生冲击时，富人和有权势的人比穷人更爱大声疾呼，更自我怜悯。也许穷人更习惯于这些冲击。也许他们对未来有较低的期望。但这些华尔街的事情并没有让我感到惊讶，尽管这很令人失望。
Adam Davidson of Planet Money, which is a co-production of our show and NPR News. You can find the Planet Money blog, or hear their great, twice-weekly podcast for absolutely free at npr.org/money. [MUSIC - "I GET MONEY" BY 50 CENT]
《Planet Money》的亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson），这是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。你可以在npr.org/money找到Planet Money的博客，或免费收听他们精彩的每周两次的播客。[音乐 - 50 Cent的“I GET MONEY”]
Act Two. Foul Play. Sports, of course, is a place where there are some of the biggest crybabies, or people who get called crybabies, anyway. And in professional basketball, in the NBA, there's a kind of institutionalized crybabying called the flop, which has not always been part of the game. One of our producers, Alex Blumberg, has been watching basketball for a long time and started to wonder if the story that basketball fans tell themselves about the origins of flop is even true. But first, a quick explanation of the flop.
第二幕。犯规。当然，体育界有一些最大的“哭闹者”，或者说被叫作“哭闹者”的人。在职业篮球界，NBA，有一种体制化的哭闹行为叫作“假摔”（flop），这并不总是比赛的一部分。我们的制片人之一，亚历克斯·布隆伯格，看篮球很长时间了，开始怀疑篮球迷们对自己讲述的关于“假摔”起源的故事是否真实。但首先，对“假摔”的一个简单解释。
What you do when you flop is that you try to sell to the referee the fact that you were fouled. So you basically pretend that somebody fouled you very hard. And you fall backwards, and you fall down perhaps, or you throw up your hands in the air, even if the contact was incidental, or in some cases, non-existent. It's acting.
当你假摔时，你试图让裁判相信你被犯规了。所以你基本上假装某人非常重地犯规了你。然后你向后倒下，也许摔倒了，或者即使接触是偶然的，或者在某些情况下根本不存在，你也举起双手。这是演戏。
I think Raja Bell flopped his way into that call. Ginobili and Bell-- two of the best floppers in the league. A little push, but not enough to draw that kind of reaction.
我认为拉贾·贝尔（Raja Bell）假摔骗到了那个判罚。吉诺比利和贝尔——联盟中最好的两个假摔者。有点推搡，但不足以引出那种反应。
And the payoff for the flop is?
假摔的回报是什么？
Then I get the ball. You committed a foul, then there's a turnover. I get the ball. You have a foul against you. If you get six fouls, you're out of the game.
然后我得到球。你犯规了，然后是一个失误。我得到球。你被记一次犯规。如果你得到六次犯规，你就出局了。
And Boozer just throws Horry to the ground.
布泽尔把霍里扔到了地上。
He didn't throw him!
他没有扔他！
And nice flop by Manu Ginobili. I thought they weren't going to call that flop anymore.
马努·吉诺比利漂亮的假摔。我以为他们不会再吹那个假摔了。
Now, there's a story that people tell about the flop, about where it came from. And can I just have you tell us that story?
现在，人们关于假摔有一个故事，关于它来自哪里。你能给我们讲讲那个故事吗？
Yes, I can. And this story is almost like hardened conventional wisdom among NBA fans. If you search on the Internet, you'll find all sorts of versions of this story. But it's best summed up by this guy Bill Simmons who wrote a post about flopping.
是的，我可以。这个故事在NBA球迷中几乎就像一种根深蒂固的传统智慧。如果你在互联网上搜索，你会发现这个故事的各种版本。但最好的总结来自那个写过关于假摔文章的比尔·西蒙斯（Bill Simmons）。
Bill Simmons is?
比尔·西蒙斯是？
Bill Simmons is a columnist for ESPN. He's got a podcast. He's this world famous sports columnist. He's got a big book. And he wrote in this post, "the single most disgusting NBA development of the past few years: the flopping. Slowly, regretfully, inexplicably, the sport is morphing into soccer." And that's because, if you watched recently the World Cup, you would see regularly in game after game, every game had this-- where it would feature two guys, a guy dribbling the ball on somebody. And then all of a sudden, the guy dribbling the ball would crash to the ground, throw up his arms, roll around grabbing his ankle, writhing in pain. And then they'd show the replay, and you'd see that nobody touched the guy. He'd just fallen over. And that happened every single game.
比尔·西蒙斯是ESPN的一位专栏作家。他有播客。他是这个世界闻名的体育专栏作家。他有一本大书。他在文章中写道，“过去几年NBA最令人作呕的发展：假摔。缓慢地、遗憾地、不可思议地，这项运动正在演变成足球。” 那是因为，如果你最近看了世界杯，你会经常看到在每场比赛中，每场比赛都有这个——它会由两个人组成，一个人运球突破另一个人。然后突然之间，运球的那个人会倒在地上，举起手臂，翻滚抓着脚踝，痛苦地挣扎。然后他们会播放回放，你会看到没有人碰到那个人。他只是倒下了。这在每一场比赛中都会发生。
And in soccer, there are players who are known as being great floppers. The word flop really comes from there.
在足球中，有些球员以擅长假摔而闻名。单词“flop”实际上就是从那里来的。
It's clearly a part of the game in soccer. And so the story goes that as more and more Europeans started playing NBA basketball, Europeans have been raised in the culture of soccer, they all embrace the culture of the flop, and then when they started playing basketball, they brought it with them to the NBA. That's the story.
这显然是足球比赛的一部分。故事就这样流传下来，随着越来越多的欧洲人开始打NBA篮球，欧洲人是在足球文化中长大的，他们都拥抱假摔文化，然后当他们开始打篮球时，他们把这种文化带到了NBA。这就是故事。
So if this conventional wisdom were true, if this legend were true, that means that somewhere, there's a patient zero. There's a player who was carrying the virus from European soccer into American basketball. Do we know who that patient zero is? Who is that crossover athlete?
如果这个传统智慧是真的，如果这个传说是真的，那意味着在某个地方，有一个“零号病人”。有一个球员把病毒从欧洲足球带到了美国篮球。我们知道那个零号病人是谁吗？那个跨界运动员是谁？
Well, we do. I did some poking around on the Internet, and everybody points to one guy. The one guy who brought the flop to the NBA. And that guy is Vlade Divac.
嗯，我们知道。我在互联网上到处查了一下，每个人都指向一个人。那个把假摔带到NBA的人。那个人就是弗拉德·迪瓦茨（Vlade Divac）。
Who'd he play for?
他为谁效力？
Well, he started playing in 1989. He started playing for the Lakers and then he played for the Sacramento Kings for a while. And then he went back to the Lakers. And Vlade Divac-- he's such the perfect patient zero, because he's this gigantic Serbian guy. He's 7'1, he's got the definition of a hangdog face. He's just got this long face with this permanent five o'clock shadow. And these sad, droopy eyes. And then his former coach Dell Harris, one time, was asked about it, and somebody asked Harris if he taught Vlade to flop, and Harris said and I quote, "are you kidding? He brought that over here and taught the whole NBA how to flop." And you would see these games, and he was always playing. And so during his heyday, he played for the Sacramento Kings. They were really good, and he was always matched up against the LA Lakers who had Shaquille O'Neal, who was the dominant, gigantic, center. He's immense, heavy, strong, super fast. He's superhuman. Impossible to guard, except Vlade Divac had to guard him all the time. And so the games were replete with scenes of Vlade Divac just sort of flopping in all sorts of manner. Shaq would turn around and Vlade would go flying back, and then the refs would call a foul on Shaq. But the problem with the flop is that it's a lie.
嗯，他1989年开始打球。他先是为湖人队效力，然后为萨克拉门托国王队效力了一段时间。然后他又回到了湖人队。弗拉德·迪瓦茨——他是如此完美的零号病人，因为他是一个巨大的塞尔维亚人。他身高7英尺1英寸，有着标志性的愁容满面的脸。他就是那张长脸，带着永久的下午五点的胡茬。还有那双悲伤、下垂的眼睛。后来他以前的教练戴尔·哈里斯（Dell Harris）有一次被问到这个问题，有人问哈里斯是否教过弗拉德假摔，哈里斯说，我引用的话，“你在开玩笑吗？是他把那东西带到这里，教了整个NBA怎么假摔。” 你会看到这些比赛，他总是在打球。所以在他鼎盛时期，他为萨克拉门托国王队效力。他们真的很强，他总是对阵拥有沙奎尔·奥尼尔（Shaquille O'Neal）的洛杉矶湖人队，奥尼尔是那个具有统治力的、巨大的中锋。他巨大、沉重、强壮、超级快。他是超人。除了弗拉德·迪瓦茨必须一直防守他，否则无法防守。所以比赛中充满了弗拉德·迪瓦茨以各种方式假摔的场景。奥尼尔一转身，弗拉德就会飞回去，然后裁判就会吹奥尼尔犯规。但假摔的问题在于它是一个谎言。
Oh right, you weren't really fouled. And yet somebody has to serve the time for you being fouled.
哦对，你并不是真的被犯规了。然而有人必须为你被犯规而付出代价。
Exactly. And so you've penalized somebody else. And then it also becomes-- if it takes a hold, it sort of self-perpetuates. It's like corruption. Once one person gets away with flopping, then an incentive is raised for other people to start flopping. Because if they're going to do it, well then I have to do it back. And then it sort of spreads very quickly.
完全正确。所以你惩罚了别人。然后它也变成了——如果它被接受，它就会自我延续。这就像腐败。一旦一个人通过假摔侥幸逃脱，那么其他人开始假摔的动机就增加了。因为如果他们要这样做，那我必须回敬。然后它很快就传播开了。
So that's the generally accepted story.
所以这就是普遍接受的故事。
Yeah, there's only one problem. It might not be true. I talked to a guy named Tommy Craggs. And he's a sports writer at this fantastic website called Deadspin, which is a sports commentary blog, and he totally disagrees with this theory.
是的，只有一个问题。它可能不是真的。我和一个叫汤米·克拉格斯（Tommy Craggs）的人谈过。他是这个很棒的网站Deadspin的体育作家，这是一个体育评论博客，他完全不同意这个理论。
I don't think Vlade Divac was the-- I don't think flopping was born with him. And I think what we see is the proliferation of flopping was really more a response to rule changes.
我不认为弗拉德·迪瓦茨是——我不认为假摔随着他诞生。我认为我们所看到的假摔的扩散实际上更多是对规则变化的反应。
So he's saying it's not the Europeans who brought this to us, it's our own rule changes. Government intervention, if you will.
所以他是说这不是欧洲人带给我们的，而是我们自己的规则变化。政府干预，如果你愿意的话。
That's exactly what he's saying.
这就是他所说的。
Bad regulation with unintended effects.
带有意想不到后果的糟糕监管。
Yes, exactly. He's saying the temptation is always to blame the culture, but really it's the regulation that changed, and it created the culture that followed. And so the specific rule change that he's talking about is, there used to be this thing in basketball called the hand check, where-- let's say you're Michael Jordan.
是的，完全正确。他说诱惑总是指责文化，但实际上是监管发生了变化，它创造了随之而来的文化。他所谈论的具体规则变化是，篮球运动中曾经有一项叫“手部接触”（hand check）的东西，如果你是迈克尔·乔丹。
Yeah, let's say that.
是的，我们就这么假设。
And I have the unenviable task of guarding you. Back when Michael Jordan played, I could put my hand on you a little bit, I could put my elbow on you. I had all these tools at my disposal to try to slow you down. Even though you were faster than I could ever hope to be, you were the most dominant offensive player ever to play the game, I had some tools that I could use to help even the score a little. But then-- partly because of Jordan, and other factors as well-- the NBA started tweaking the rules, and they made the hand check illegal.
我有一个不可逾越的任务要防守你。在迈克尔·乔丹打球的时候，我可以把手放在你身上一点，我可以把肘放在你身上。我手里有所有这些工具来试图让你慢下来。尽管你比我能想象的要快得多，你是史上最强大的进攻球员，我还是有一些工具可以用来稍微拉平比分。但后来——部分是因为乔丹，以及其他因素——NBA开始调整规则，他们使手部接触变为非法。
So you can't touch at all.
所以你根本不能碰。
You still do. But yes, it gets whistled a lot more. It's called as a foul a lot more. And so what that means is that as a defensive player-- say I'm a slow defensive player, and I'm playing a fast offense player, whereas before I could hold them, muscle them around a little bit, now I got nothing.
你仍然可以。但是的，它被吹罚的次数更多了。它被判犯规的次数更多了。所以这意味着作为一名防守球员——假设我是一名缓慢的防守球员，我在防守一名快速的进攻球员，以前我可以抱住他们，稍微强硬一点，现在我什么都没有了。
A flop is the defensive player's last resort. And it's something that a defensive player can do to gain a tiny advantage back. And the incentive to do it is incredibly high. I mean, by drawing an offensive foul, it's a turnover and a foul on your opponent. And I think there have been studies that show that there's a small correlation between winning and teams that draw offensive fouls.
假摔是防守球员最后的手段。这是防守球员可以做的一件事，可以获得微小的优势。这样做的动力非常高。我的意思是，通过制造进攻犯规，这是一个失误，对方还要背上犯规。我认为已经有研究表明，胜利与那些制造进攻犯规的球队之间存在微小的相关性。
Now, Tommy Craggs also takes issue with the convention wisdom in the second way as well. Most basketball fans, if you talk to them about flopping, they say it is a scourge upon the game. They hate it, and they think it's the sissifying and Europization of the game. Rasheed Wallace, he's a player in the NBA. He's also very outspoken. He's one of my favorite players. And Rasheed, he's somebody that people point to a lot as being a whiner and a crybaby, because he constantly complains to the refs about getting fouled himself. But he hates it when people flop. And he was playing this game, and his opponents had been flopping, and he said that's not basketball. That's entertainment. So that's this other conventional view. Tommy Craggs, though, he doesn't mind flopping.
现在，汤米·克拉格斯在第二点上也对传统智慧提出了异议。大多数篮球迷，如果你和他们谈论假摔，他们说这是比赛的祸害。他们讨厌它，他们认为这是比赛的“娘娘腔”和“欧洲化”。拉希德·华莱士（Rasheed Wallace）是NBA的一名球员。他也非常直言不讳。他是我最喜欢的球员之一。拉希德，他是人们经常指出是一个抱怨者和哭闹者的人，因为他不断向裁判抱怨自己被犯规。但他讨厌别人假摔。他在打那场比赛，他的对手一直在假摔，他说那不是篮球。那是娱乐。所以这是另一种传统的看法。但汤米·克拉格斯不介意假摔。
I think with flopping in particular, it's the tax we pay to have a more liberated game, to have a more offensive-oriented game. I think what you would call the flopping era. It's also the more beautiful era.
我认为假摔特别是一种税，是我们为拥有更自由的比赛，拥有更偏向进攻的比赛而付出的代价。我认为你会称之为假摔时代。这也是更美丽的时代。
It's also the dunking era, and the amazing drive to the basket era, and the behind the back pass era. And a lot of other really exciting things that people like about basketball has come hand-in-hand with the flopping era.
这也是扣篮时代，令人惊叹的突破到篮下时代，以及背后传球时代。人们喜欢的许多其他非常令人兴奋的事情与假摔时代齐头并进。
Yeah. And if it means we have a more beautiful game, I can live with players occasionally doing the death scene from Little Women.
是的。如果这意味着我们拥有更美丽的比赛，我可以忍受球员偶尔表演《小妇人》中的死亡场景。
You know, there was this incident recently where Derek Jeter was standing at the plate and pretended that he got hit with a ball and got a free base. This is a baseball game. And then looking back at the video, you see oh, the ball didn't even touch him. But he totally faked it. And there was a debate about well, was this right? Was this what baseball should be? And do you think that at this point, since the flop exists in soccer, since it exists in basketball, that now basically it's like a pan-sports movement? That basically it's just in the culture, and now anybody can grab at it in any sport and it's just out there?
你知道，最近发生了这样一件事：德里克·杰特（Derek Jeter）站在本垒处，假装他被球击中，并获得了一个免费的一垒。这是一场棒球比赛。然后回头看视频，你看到哦，球甚至没碰他。但他完全是伪造的。关于这是否正确，是否存在争议？这是棒球应该有的样子吗？你认为在这一点上，既然假摔存在于足球中，既然它存在于篮球中，现在基本上就像是一场“泛体育运动”了吗？基本上它就在文化中，现在任何人都可以把它抓到任何运动中，它就出现在那里？
Yeah, I do. I don't think if we just had the World Cup, where you saw players flopping all over the place, I don't think that Derek Jeter would have necessarily had that idea. I mean, it's harder to flop in baseball, there aren't as many opportunities. But I don't think he would have done that if it wasn't for the expansion of flopping throughout professional sports. Like, Derek Jeter-- he's unquestionably one of the best players ever to play baseball, and so in a certain sense-- to be that good, you have to have this do whatever it takes to win mentality. There's just no way that you can achieve his level without having this incredibly competitive streak in you.
是的，我有这种感觉。我不认为如果我们刚刚没有进行世界杯，在那里你看到球员到处假摔，德里克·杰特就不一定会想到那个主意。我的意思是，在棒球中更难假摔，机会没有那么多。但我不认为如果不是因为假摔在职业体育界蔓延，他会那么做。就像，德里克·杰特——他毫无疑问是史上最伟大的棒球运动员之一，所以在某种意义上——要变得那么好，你必须拥有这种“不惜一切代价取胜”的心态。如果没有这种极其强烈的竞争意识，你是不可能达到他的水平的。
But can you imagine Michael Jordan flopping?
但你能想象迈克尔·乔丹假摔吗？
No.
不。
There would be just no dignity it it.
那样做根本没有任何尊严。
No. But see, that's not fair. It's like, can you imagine God cheating on a test? God doesn't need to cheat on a test. You know what I mean?
不。但看，这不公平。这就像是，你能想象上帝在考试中作弊吗？上帝不需要在考试中作弊。你知道我的意思吗？
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our show. Coming up: how to make a living by complaining. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来：如何靠抱怨谋生。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show: crybabies, stories of whiners, complainers, malcontents, and how being a crybaby can get you what you need and get results, and maybe even sometimes yes, justice. We have arrived at Act three of our show. Act Three. The Squeaky Wheelchair Gets the Grease. In California, a kind of a crybaby cottage industry has popped up around, of all things, the Americans with Disabilities Act, the federal law that requires all public places to meet a minimum level of accessibility-- parking spaces, ramps, grab bars in the bathroom. Some people have taken to suing hundreds of business owners for not being up to code. Alex MacInnis hung out with one of them.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为你带来关于这个主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目：哭闹者，关于抱怨者、发牢骚者、不满者的故事，以及作为一个“哭闹者”如何能让你得到你所需要的并取得成果，甚至有时，是的，公正。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕。吱吱作响的轮椅能得到润滑油。在加利福尼亚州，围绕《美国残疾人法案》（ADA）这一联邦法律，出现了一种“哭闹者”家庭产业，该法案要求所有公共场所达到最低的可及性水平——停车位、坡道、浴室里的扶手。有些人已经开始起诉数百名不符合法规的企业主。亚历克斯·麦金尼斯（Alex MacInnis）和其中一人待在一起。
Behind a furniture store in West Los Angeles, I'm on a tour of handicap parking spaces with a guy named Tom Mundy. He drives a baby blue minivan. A handicap placard dangles from his rear-view mirror.
在西洛杉矶的一家家具店后面，我正在和一个叫汤姆·蒙迪（Tom Mundy）的人一起参观残疾人停车位。他开着一辆婴儿蓝色的微型面包车。残疾人停车牌悬挂在他的后视镜上。
I'm backing into a handicap spot. I'm going to show you what this place is making me use.
我正在倒车进入一个残疾人停车位。我要向你展示这个地方强迫我使用什么。
Tom flips one of several toggle switches on his dashboard.
汤姆拨动了他仪表板上的几个拨动开关中的一个。
All right. Stand clear.
好吧。请让开。
And the van's side door slides open. A ramp unfolds into the empty space next to the handicap spot, which is striped with diagonal lines to keep anyone from parking there. He is showing producer Brian Reed and me why this spot is, for him, completely useless. That striped space, the access aisle, is only five feet wide.
面包车的侧门滑开了。一个坡道展开在残疾人停车位旁边的空地上，那里画着对角线，以防止任何人停车。他正在向制片人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）和我展示为什么这个车位对他来说完全没用。那个有条纹的空间，即通道，只有五英尺宽。
So, here is a typical handicap spot without an eight foot access aisle.
所以，这是一个没有八英尺宽通道的典型残疾人停车位。
So can you try to get out? Can you--
那么你能试着出来吗？你能——
I can get out. I'm going to roll right into the bushes if you want me to get out.
我可以出来。如果你想让我出来，我就直接滚进灌木丛里。
I'd love to see you try. It'd be dramatic. Unless you feel it's going to be painful.
我很乐意看到你试一下。那会很戏剧性。除非你觉得这会很痛苦。
I can't-- how am I going to-- I don't know if I can turn around and get out. And come back up. There's not enough room at the bottom of my ramp, and I would end up in the bushes.
我不能——我怎么能——我不知道我是否能转身出来。然后再上来。我的坡道底部没有足够的空间，我会最终滚进灌木丛里。
A while back, Tom came here to buy a dining room table. But when he couldn't get out of his van, he sued the owner of the parking lot under the ADA, the Americans with Disabilities Act. California is one of only a few states where, rather than just suing to get the problem fixed, you can actually sue for money that goes to you-- $4,000 per violation. And Tom, like a handful of other people in California, makes his living doing this over and over. He has no other job. It's his sole means of support.
不久前，汤姆来这里买一张餐厅桌子。但当他无法从面包车里出来时，他根据ADA即《美国残疾人法案》起诉了停车场的所有者。加利福尼亚州是少数几个不仅起诉要求修复问题，而且实际上可以起诉获得属于你个人的赔偿金的州之一——每次违规4000美元。汤姆，像加利福尼亚州的其他少数人一样，靠不断地这样做为生。他没有其他工作。这是他唯一的经济来源。
All right, so you just want to follow me Alex?
好吧，所以你只是想跟着我，亚历克斯？
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
For the next hour, Tom leads us along eight blocks, pointing out a half dozen businesses he's sued. From the first parking lot, we cross the street to a cramped strip mall with a dry cleaners, a beauty salon and a store that sells breast feeding supplies.
在接下来的一个小时里，汤姆带着我们沿着八个街区走，指出了他起诉过的六家企业。从第一个停车场开始，我们穿过街道来到一个拥挤的带状购物中心，那里有干洗店、美容院和一家销售母乳喂养用品的商店。
We're in another parking lot, and once again, I'm trapped in my van. I can't get out.
我们在另一个停车场，再一次，我被困在我的面包车里了。我出不去。
Next, down the road, a steakhouse with a giant medal cow hanging proudly over the entrance.
接下来，沿着路走，一家牛排馆，入口上方挂着一头巨大的金属奶牛。
And we just drove through their gigantic parking lot and there's zero parking for disabled.
我们刚刚开车经过他们巨大的停车场，那里没有残疾人停车位。
Then there's this McDonald's around the corner, which actually fixed its parking lot because of Tom's lawsuit. I asked Tom, how many ADA violations are in this one neighborhood, if he had to guess. He says hundreds.
然后是转角的这家麦当劳，因为它实际上因为汤姆的诉讼修复了停车场。我问汤姆，在这个社区里有多少ADA违规行为，如果他必须猜的话。他说有几百个。
Do you have any estimates as to how many lawsuits you brought within this one-mile radius? Like, more than 10?
你对你在这一英里半径内提起的诉讼数量有什么估计吗？比如，超过10个？
I would say probably more than 10 where we're sitting right now.
我会说可能超过10个，就在我们现在坐的地方。
Would you say that you might have brought as many as 50 lawsuits in this area?
你会说你在这个地区可能提起了多达50起诉讼吗？
I would say in West LA, probably at least 50 right where I'm sitting now.
我会说在西洛杉矶，就在我现在坐的地方，可能至少有50起。
That's 50 lawsuits in West LA alone. Tom's best guess for how many he's filed altogether since moving to California three years ago-- over 500. Tom won't say how much he makes doing this. Most cases settle out of court for a thousand or two. But one attorney, who regularly defends business owners in these cases, estimated Tom has pulled in upwards of half a million dollars in three years.
那仅仅在西洛杉矶就有50起诉讼。汤姆对自己三年前搬到加利福尼亚以来总共提起了多少起诉讼的最佳猜测——超过500起。汤姆不愿透露他通过这样做赚了多少钱。大多数案件在法庭外以一两千美元的价格和解。但一位经常在这些案件中为企业主辩护的律师估计，汤姆在三年内赚了超过50万美元。
I don't want to talk about the money side of it. I think a lot of people focus on the money issue, and it's not always about the money. It's about compliance, and the stuff should have been done by the time I got there.
我不想谈论金钱方面的问题。我认为很多人关注金钱问题，但这并不总是关于金钱。这是关于合规性，这些事情在我到达那里的时候就应该做好了。
Do you think people misunderstand what you're doing sometimes?
你认为人们有时会误解你在做什么吗？
No, I think most of the time they're misinformed, and they just don't understand. And I've said several times, I have another wheelchair if you want to sit in it, I can take out, and take you around and show you just little things. Not big things like being carried up the steps to get upstairs into a restaurant, but just small things. And nobody's ever taken me up on that.
不，我认为大多数时候他们是被误导了，他们只是不明白。我已经说过好几次了，如果你想坐在轮椅里，我还有另一个轮椅，我可以带出来，带你四处转转，给你看一些小事情。不是像被搬上台阶才能进餐厅这种大事，只是小事情。从来没有人接受我的提议。
After Tom broke his back in a Motocross accident in 1988 he had several jobs in the construction business reviewing blueprints for compliance with accessibility rules. One company was on a second floor walk up, so he worked all alone reviewing blueprints in a closet on the first floor. The bathroom was on the second floor, so if he had to go, he had to get in his van and drive to a gas station across the street. He tried to start his own consulting company to help businesses get up to code, but owners didn't seem interested. So with the ADA on the books for more than 15 years, and Tom still seeing infractions on a daily basis, he finally decided the gloves were coming off. And that's when he found his attorney, Morse Mehrban.
1988年汤姆在一次摩托车越野赛事故中摔断背部后，他在建筑行业有几份审查蓝图以符合无障碍规则的工作。一家公司在二楼的步行街上，所以他独自一人在楼下的壁橱里审查蓝图。浴室在二楼，所以如果他必须去，他必须进入面包车，开车去街对面的加油站。他试图创办自己的咨询公司来帮助企业达到法规要求，但业主似乎不感兴趣。所以，ADA生效超过15年了，汤姆仍然每天看到违规行为，他最终决定不再客气了。那就是他找到他的律师莫尔斯·梅尔班（Morse Mehrban）的时候。
Mr. Mundy, and others like him, have decided enough is enough and being treated as second class citizens is not something they want to live with anymore. And the law is on their side.
蒙迪先生和像他这样的人已经决定“受够了”，被视为二等公民不再是他们想忍受的生活。法律站在他们这一边。
Mehrban has become sort of like the Walmart of ADA lawsuits. He does a high volume of litigation, most cases for extremely low margins. He's handled so many lawsuits, he says he's lost track. But the number is definitely in the thousands. The law allows you to sue for lawyer's fees on top of what the disabled person gets, so Mehrban's pulling in at least six figures from these lawsuits too. His website asks, confined to a wheelchair in California? You may be entitled to $4,000. You stop by a hardware store and need to use the restroom, but find there are no grab bars next to the toilet, you may be entitled to $4,000. You're in a restaurant and want to use the restroom mirror to make yourself presentable. The mirror is mounted too high on the wall for you to use. You may be entitled to $4,000. Mehrban allows that some people may find suing for large sums of money over a bathroom mirror distasteful. But he insists that without the monetary incentives, the ADA would essentially be toothless.
梅尔班已经成为了ADA诉讼的“沃尔玛”。他处理大量的诉讼，大多数案件的利润率极低。他处理了太多的诉讼，他说他已经记不清了。但数字绝对是成千上万。法律允许你在残疾人获得赔偿的基础上起诉索要律师费，所以梅尔班也从这些诉讼中获得了至少六位数的收入。他的网站问道，“在加利福尼亚被困在轮椅里？你可能有权获得4000美元。” 你停在五金店需要使用洗手间，但发现马桶旁边没有扶手，你可能有权获得4000美元。你在餐厅里想用洗手间的镜子让自己看起来体面一点。镜子挂在墙上太高，你无法使用。你可能有权获得4000美元。梅尔班承认，有些人可能会觉得因为一面洗手间镜子而起诉要求巨额资金是令人反感的。但他坚持认为，如果没有金钱激励，ADA本质上是无力的。
You know, even in the old wild west, they provided for monetary compensation if you were to catch an outlaw and bring him back to justice. So this goes back a long time. We're dealing with business people here. If a business person things he can save even a penny by doing or not doing something, they're going to do or not do that thing.
你知道，即使在古老的狂野西部，如果你抓住歹徒并将他带回正义，他们也提供了金钱补偿。所以这可以追溯到很久以前。我们在这里打交道的是生意人。如果一个生意人认为他可以通过做或不做某事节省一分钱，他就会做或不做那件事。
This is how the ADA was designed, to have virtually no enforcement other than a disabled person angry enough to file a lawsuit. After a building's built, nobody checks up on it's ADA compliance. That's not in the jurisdiction of any health inspector, or OSHA, or the Tax Board, or the EPA, or the state troopers, nobody. So it's been to Mehrban, and a handful of other lawyers doing high volume ADA law, to help make California one of the most accessible ADA-complaint states in the nation, as well as one of the most lawsuit-prone. Attorneys say well over 14,000 ADA-related lawsuits have been filed in the state.
这就是ADA的设计方式，除了愤怒到足以提起诉讼的残疾人之外，几乎没有任何执法。建筑物建成后，没有人检查其ADA合规性。这不在任何健康检查员、OSHA（职业安全与健康管理局）、税务委员会、环境保护署或州警的管辖范围内，没人管。所以，梅尔班和少数其他从事大量ADA法律的律师，帮助加利福尼亚州成为全国ADA合规性最强、同时也是最容易发生诉讼的州之一。律师们说，该州已经提起了超过14000起与ADA相关的诉讼。
When you do not do the absolute minimum to accommodate people who are in wheelchairs, that's tantamount to intentional discrimination. And this is what they deserve, frankly.
当你甚至没有做最低限度来容纳坐轮椅的人时，这等同于蓄意歧视。老实说，这就是他们应得的。
Yeah. I got the papers here, if you ever want to look at them.
是的。我有文件在这里，如果你想看的话。
At La Cienega Car Wash, not far from West Hollywood, Maurice Golnirahi has just been notified that his family business is being sued for $4,000.
在西好莱坞附近的拉谢内加（La Cienega）洗车场，莫里斯·戈尔尼拉希（Maurice Golnirahi）刚刚接到通知，他的家族企业正因4000美元被起诉。
And so what does it say? What's going on?
那它说了什么？发生了什么事？
On or about September 21, 2009, while patronizing said place of public accommodation, plaintiff wanted, but was unable, to use facility's restroom mirror and coat hook because they were mounted too high above the floor.
在2009年9月21日左右，当光顾上述公共场所时，原告想要，但无法使用设施的洗手间镜子和衣帽钩，因为它们安装得太高了。
The person suing in this case is not Tom Mundy, but another prolific client of Morse Mehrban named Alfredo Garcia.
在这种情况下起诉的人不是汤姆·蒙迪，而是莫尔斯·梅尔班的另一位多产客户，名叫阿尔弗雷多·加西亚（Alfredo Garcia）。
Someone's using the bathroom.
有人在使用洗手间。
Maurice leads me to the wash room to look at the alleged violations.
莫里斯带我去洗手间查看所谓的违规行为。
The mirror, here's the mirror--
镜子，这是镜子——
The bottom of the mirror hangs fairly low, almost down to the top of the sink handles, but apparently not low enough.
镜子的底部挂得相当低，几乎到了水槽把手的顶部，但显然还是不够低。
The coat hanger is right here. So I mean, this thing's pretty tall but-- I don't know. I'll give him a free car wash if he wants. It doesn't make sense for me to pay $4,000 for someone that can't hang their coat up. I understand he's handicapped, but nothing to sue about. He could have at least told us or let us know. I just think it's really shady that someone that's using their disability to sue other people and-- it's ridiculous. I mean, all he has to do is unscrew it and bring it down. It's not a big deal, so--
衣架就在这里。所以我的意思是，这东西很高，但——我不知道。如果他想要，我会给他免费洗车。我支付4000美元给一个不能挂外套的人是不合理的。我理解他是残疾人，但这不值得起诉。他至少可以告诉我们或让我们知道。我只是觉得，有人利用自己的残疾来起诉别人真的很卑鄙——这太荒谬了。我的意思是，他所要做的就是拧开它并把它降下来。这不是什么大事，所以——
It's a long list. You're going to look at your parking. Is it leveled? Is it right amount of parking? is the striping correct?
这是一份很长的清单。你将要看你的停车场。它是平的吗？停车位数量对吗？条纹画对了吗？
Kim Blackseth has been helping business owners comply with access regulations since even before the ADA. He runs a private consulting firm that specializes in this. He started using a wheelchair after his own Motocross accident in 1979.
金·布莱克塞思（Kim Blackseth）甚至在ADA之前就开始帮助企业主遵守无障碍法规。他经营着一家专门研究此项研究的私人咨询公司。他在1979年自己的摩托车越野赛事故后开始使用轮椅。
Are you going up to the entry door and finding the signage, the hardware, the effort, the landing, the kick plate? And we haven't got inside yet.
你是在走到入口门并寻找标牌、硬件、阻力、着陆区、踢脚板吗？我们还没有进去。
The rules are complicated, partially because they take into account so many different disabilities, and partially because they're really detailed.
规则很复杂，部分原因是它们考虑了如此多不同的残疾，部分原因是它们真的很详细。
There's not a facility or building in the state of California I can't find a technical barrier. I can find a technical barrier anywhere. That is no challenge to go down the street and find technical violations. And if that is your mission when you get up in the morning, you can do it. The question is, is that worthwhile? Is it important? If you can't park because there should have been two spaces, that's not a barrier. What happened if you pulled up and there's two disabled people there? Find somewhere else to park. You guys go to places all the time, the parking-- what do you do? You find somewhere else to park.
在加利福尼亚州没有任何设施或建筑是我找不到技术障碍的。我可以随处找到技术障碍。走到街上找到技术违规行为并不具有挑战性。如果你早上起床时使命就是那样，你可以做到。问题是，那值得吗？那重要吗？如果你因为本该有两个车位却没停下车而停不了车，那不是障碍。如果你开过去发现有两个残疾人在那里怎么办？找别的地方停车。你们一直去各个地方，停车——你们做什么？你们找别的地方停车。
Kim is quick to add that lawsuits are a huge part of why California is so accessible, and a lot of the suits are well-deserved. He's even sued a few businesses himself when push far enough. But because there have been so many lawsuits, he says business owners are increasingly suspicious of disabled people.
金很快补充说，诉讼是加利福尼亚州如此无障碍的一个巨大原因，很多诉讼也是应得的。当被逼到绝境时，他甚至亲自起诉过几家企业。但因为有太多的诉讼，他说企业主对残疾人越来越怀疑。
I mean I can go into restaurants or try to rent a room, and you can feel the tension. When you go into a restaurant, you can feel as they come over it's like, is he going to sue me? You can feel it. I can feel it.
我的意思是，我可以进入餐厅或尝试租房间，你可以感觉到那种紧张感。当你进入一家餐厅，你可以感觉到他们走过来时就像是，他要起诉我吗？你可以感觉到它。我可以感觉到它。
Sometimes Kim sees the lawsuits, which are supposed to increase accessibility for disabled people, having the exact opposite effect.
有时金看到诉讼，这些诉讼本应增加残疾人的可及性，却产生了完全相反的效果。
I travel a lot with this business. I called to get an accessible room, and generally speaking, those rooms are increasingly unavailable. And when I talk to clients who I represent with motels they say, if somebody calls for an accessible room, I won't rent it. It's not worth the $150. And then the risk that there's something wrong for a night's rental in that room isn't worth it to me-- hotel becomes full.
我经常随这个业务出差。我打电话去订一个无障碍房间，总的来说，那些房间越来越不可用了。当我与我代表的旅馆客户交谈时，他们说，如果有人打电话订无障碍房间，我不会租给他们。那不值150美元。而且那个房间里有什么地方不对的风险对于一晚上的租金来说不值得我考虑——酒店会满员的。
I think people don't completely get access.
我认为人们并不完全理解可及性。
Attorney Margaret Johnson is one of California's key advocates for disability rights. As it stands now, she says, the law leaves disabled people in a very awkward place sometimes, because there are so many situations where you don't want to have to sue.
律师玛格丽特·约翰逊（Margaret Johnson）是加利福尼亚州残疾人权利的主要倡导者之一。她说，目前法律让残疾人在某些时候处于非常尴尬的境地，因为有太多的情况是你不想起诉的。
To get the hairdresser that you want, that does your hair how you want it done, you all are willing to go through heck for that person. I tell you, it's like-- and you guys are looking at me like, it's that important? With that hair?
为了得到你想要的理发师，那个能按你想要的方式给你理发的人，你们所有人都不惜一切代价去支持那个人。我告诉你，这就像——而且你们看着我的样子，它有那么重要吗？那个发型？
Now, just for the record, Margaret has a very classy bob, with almost Louise Brooks-y bangs. It was cut by a woman Margaret discovered when she first moved to Sacramento. Margaret loved her work, and to make things even better, the salon the hairdresser worked at had a van-accessible parking space. Needless to say, Margaret became a regular. Until one day last fall when Margaret showed up to find something weird. The striped blue access aisle, that made the spot van-accessible, was painted over and converted into an extra parking space. She could park her van, but she couldn't get out of it-- the same problem you heard Tom Mundy complain about earlier. The salon's in a busy part of town without much street parking, but she found a space on the street and navigated her way back.
现在，顺便说一下，玛格丽特有一个非常有气质的波波头，刘海几乎像路易丝·布鲁克斯（Louise Brooks）。它是玛格丽特刚搬到萨克拉门托时发现的一位女士剪的。玛格丽特喜欢她的作品，而且更好的是，理发师工作的沙龙有一个微型面包车可及的停车位。不用说，玛格丽特成了常客。直到去年秋天有一天，玛格丽特走进来发现了一些奇怪的事情。那个让车位可以供面包车使用的蓝色条纹通道被刷掉了，改建成了额外的停车位。她可以停她的面包车，但她无法出来——你之前听到的汤姆·蒙迪抱怨的那个问题。沙龙在城镇的一个繁忙地段，没有多少街道停车位，但她在街上找到一个位置，并设法回到那里。
So I told my hair cutter. She said, oh yeah, that's a good point. I'll make sure the owners know. Next time I went, it was still like that. I mentioned it to her again. And she said, OK I'll let the owners know again. Next time I went it was still like that. She said, OK let me drag one of the owners out and show him what you're talking about. So actually I had him come out, I got in my van. And so I showed him how big the ramp was, and how much space I needed to get off the ramp and around, and why it needed to be there. And his response was, oh, the city came out and painted over it. So I'm like, pfft, no idea why the city would come out and paint over this, but whatever. So he said he would look into it.
所以我告诉了我的理发师。她说，哦是的，那是个好观点。我会确保业主知道。下次我去的时候，它还是那样。我又跟她提了一次。她说，好的，我会让业主再次知道。下次我去的时候它还是那样。她说，好的，让我把其中一个业主拉出来给你看看你在说什么。所以实际上我让他出来，我上了我的面包车。我给他看了坡道有多大，我需要多少空间才能从坡道下来，为什么它需要在这里。他的回答是，哦，是市政府出来把它涂掉的。所以我像，呸，没主意为什么市政府会出来把这个涂掉，但随便吧。所以他说他会调查。
So I just went last night and it was still that way. Now luckily, last night no one was parked in that space. So I kind of straddled it so that nobody could get next to me. But I mean, I don't know. I just feel like that's an example of-- here's a business that had access, even. And they took it away. They don't really know why they took it away. And they don't seem to have any interest in putting it back. Now, I love my hair cutter, so much that I keep putting up with it. And I haven't done a letter, I haven't filed a lawsuit. And part of it's just I don't want to be-- when you start doing that stuff, you start being the bad disabled person who is getting on a business's case because they're not doing the access stuff. And it puts me in a position to have to be the bitchy, crabby, pushy disabled person that nobody like or wants to deal with, because they want disabled people to be nice and smiling and friendly and get along and not make waves and just go along with the program. It's an emotional toll. I don't know how to explain that better. I mean, why can't I just say this is an issue, fix it, and it can be done? Why do I have to be pushed to the point of doing a lawsuit?
所以我昨晚才去过，它仍然是那样。幸运的是，昨晚那个位置没有人停车。所以我把它横跨过来，这样没人能停在我旁边。但我的意思是，我不知道。我觉得这就是一个例子——这是一个甚至有可及性的企业。他们把它拿走了。他们真的不知道为什么要把它拿走。他们似乎也没有兴趣把它放回去。现在，我太爱我的理发师了，以至于我一直在忍受它。我没有写信，我没有提起诉讼。部分原因只是我不想成为——当你开始做那些事情时，你开始成为那个坏的残疾人，因为企业不做可及性的事情而纠缠他们。这让我不得不成为每个人都不喜欢或不想处理的那个刻薄、暴躁、咄咄逼人的残疾人，因为他们想要残疾人变得友好、面带微笑、和蔼，顺从，不制造麻烦，只跟着计划走。这是一个情感上的代价。我不知道如何更好地解释这一点。我的意思是，为什么我不能只是说这是一个问题，修复它，然后它就可以完成了？为什么我必须被逼到提起诉讼的地步？
Keep in mind that Margaret is a lawyer. She has sued people personally, and she's been involved in large class action suits over disability access. By choosing not to have an agency monitoring these laws, something like OSHA or a building inspector, we've invited individuals to seek their own justice, to decide for themselves what they're willing to put up with, what is worth fighting over, and when, if ever, it pays to ask nicely.
请记住，玛格丽特是一名律师。她亲自起诉过别人，也参与过有关残疾人可及性的大型集体诉讼。通过选择不设立监管这些法律的机构，例如OSHA或建筑检查员，我们邀请个人寻求自己的正义，自己决定他们愿意忍受什么，什么值得争论，以及在什么时候（如果可能的话）礼貌地要求是否值得。
Alex MacInnis in Los Angeles. [MUSIC - "WHEELS" BY FLYING BURRITO BOYS]
洛杉矶的亚历克斯·麦金尼斯。[音乐 - Flying Burrito Boys的“WHEELS”]
Act Four. Cry Me a Liver. We close our show today with this fable about being a crybaby from David Sedaris.
第四幕。为我哭泣的肝脏。我们今天以戴维·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）的这个关于成为一个“哭闹者”的寓言来结束我们的节目。
The white rat had been sick for as long as he could remember. If it wasn't a headache, it was an upset stomach, a sore throat an eye infection. Pus seeped from his gums. His ears rang, and what little he ate went right through him. Now came the news that he had pancreatic cancer, which was actually something of a relief. "Finally, I can die," he moaned to his new roommate. She was a female, also white and had arrived only that morning. The tank they shared was made of glass. It's walls soiled here and there with bloody paw prints and flecks or vomit.
小白鼠从他记事起就一直在生病。如果不是头痛，就是胃不舒服、喉咙痛、眼睛感染。脓从他的牙龈渗出。他的耳朵里嗡嗡作响，吃的一点东西也直接排了出来。现在传来了他患有胰腺癌的消息，这实际上是一种解脱。“终于，我可以死了，”他对他新来的室友呻吟道。她是一只雌性，也是白色的，那天早上才到。他们共享的坦克是玻璃做的。墙壁上这里那里沾满了血迹斑斑的爪印和呕吐物的斑点。
"Well," she sighed, wincing at the state of her new home. "I'm sorry to say it, but if you have a terminal illness, it's nobody's fault but your own."
“好吧，”她叹了口气，对她新家的状况畏缩了一下。“我很抱歉这么说，但如果你患有绝症，那不是任何人的错，除了你自己的。”
"I beg your pardon," said the white rat. This female approached the water bottle, stuck her paws into the spigot, and began to wash them.
“请原谅我，”小白鼠说。这只雌性接近水瓶，把爪子伸进龙头，开始清洗它们。
"It's nice to believe that these sicknesses just befall us," she said. "We blame them on our environment and insist that they can happen to anyone, but in truth, we bring them on ourselves with hatefulness and negativity. You might not have realized how negative you were being. Maybe you were passive-aggressive. Maybe no one cared enough to point it out, but I have to call things like I see them, just as everyone does to me only in the opposite direction." 'How come you're always so sunny,' they ask, 'and doesn't your mouth hurt from all that smiling?' Some interpret it as over-exuberance but to me, it's a kind of vaccine. As long as I'm happy and I love everybody, I can't get sick."
“相信这些疾病只是降临在我们身上是很好的，”她说。“我们把它们归咎于我们的环境，并坚持认为它们可能发生在任何人身上，但实际上，我们用仇恨和消极情绪给自己带来了它们。你可能没有意识到你有多消极。也许你是被动攻击的。也许没有人足够关心指出它，但我必须像我看到的那样说出来，就像每个人对我都做的那样，只是相反的方向。‘你怎么总是那么阳光，’他们问，‘而且你的嘴巴不会因为一直笑而痛吗？’有些人将其解释为过度亢奋，但对我来说，这是一种疫苗。只要我快乐，我爱每个人，我就不会生病。”
"Never," asked the white rat.
“永远不会吗？”小白鼠问。
"Oh, I had a flu once, but it was completely my own fault. Someone I mistook for a friend took to criticizing me behind my back, saying things regarding my weight and so forth. I got wind of it and for all of three minutes I wished her ill. I'm not talking death, just a little discomfort. Cramping, mainly. I was just starting to visualize it when I sneezed, which was my body's way of saying, whoa that's not cool. Then my nose stopped up and I came down with a fever."
“哦，我得过一次流感，但这完全是我自己的错。一个我误以为是朋友的人开始在背后批评我，说一些关于我体重的事情等等。我听到了，在整整三分钟里，我祝她不顺。我不是在说死亡，只是稍微不舒服。主要是抽筋。我刚开始想象它的时候，我就打了个喷嚏，这是我身体说‘哇，那不酷’的方式。然后我的鼻子塞住了，我发烧了。”
"And what about your supposed friend, the one who said cruel things behind your back? If you got a flu, what happened to her," asked the white rat.
“那么你那个所谓的背后说刻薄话的朋友呢？如果你得了流感，她怎么样了？”小白鼠问。
"Well, nothing yet," the female said, "but sometimes the body bides its time." Her pink eyes narrowed just slightly. "I can bet when something does happen, though, it will be a lot worse than a flu. Diabetes maybe."
“嗯，目前还没有，”雌性说，“但有时身体在等待时机。” 她粉红色的眼睛稍微眯了起来。“我可以打赌，当事情真的发生时，情况会比流感糟糕得多。也许是糖尿病。”
"You sound pretty hopeful." the white rat observed.
“你听起来很有希望，”小白鼠观察到。
The female scowled, then smiled so hard the corners of her mouth touched her eyes. "Not at all, I wish her the best."
雌性皱起眉头，然后笑得嘴角碰到了眼睛。“根本不是，我祝她一切顺利。”
The white rat slumped against the wall and put a hand to his forehead. "I can't think of anybody I dislike. Then too, I've been alone since my last roommate died."
小白鼠靠在墙上，手抚在额头上。“我无法想到任何我不喜欢的人。而且，我从上一个室友死后就一直一个人。”
"That's another cause of cancer." the female told him. "You need to get out, socialize. Storytelling is pivotal to our well-being, as are non-ethnic jokes and riddles." Food pellets dropped from a chute beside the water bottle, and she took a bite of one. "I heard somewhere that limericks can cure both heart disease and certain types of cancer, can you beat that?"
“那是癌症的另一个原因，”雌性告诉他。“你需要出去，社交。讲故事对我们的健康至关重要，非民族笑话和谜语也是如此。” 食物颗粒从水瓶旁边的滑槽掉下来，她吃了一口。“我在某处听说顺口溜可以治愈心脏病和某些类型的癌症，你能打败那个吗？”
"Limericks," the white rat knitted his brow.
“顺口溜，”小白鼠皱起了眉头。
"They're poems." The female explained. "You know, like 'there once was a mouse da-da-da, who died at a da-da-da-da.'"
“它们是诗，”雌性解释道。“你知道，比如‘曾经有一只老鼠哒哒哒，死在哒哒哒哒。’”
"Oh right," said the rat, and silently recalling one about a prostitute and a dead cat, he chuckled. "And what about haiku? Are those good for curing shorter diseases?"
“哦，对，”老鼠说，默默地想起一个关于妓女和死猫的笑话，他轻声笑了。“那么俳句呢？那些对治疗较短的疾病有好处吗？”
"I know when I'm being mocked," the female said, "but that's OK. You're sick and are going to die. I, meanwhile, am perfectly healthy with good teeth and a positive attitude toward life, so joke away if it makes you feel any better." She just cracked open that smile of hers when the mesh ceiling parted, and a human hand appeared. At first it seemed to be made of wax, that's how rigid and opaque it was. But as it neared and pinned her to the floor, the female smelled rubber and understood that it was encased in a glove. Then came a second hand, this one bearing a hypodermic needle. And as the tip sank into her stomach, releasing its mad punch of viruses, the white rat settled against the wood chips and thought, most limericks, it seemed to him, involved a place. 'There was a young mole from Des Moines,' say. Or 'in Yorktown there once lived a ferret.' He didn't know where he was, though. It was a lab obviously, but the location was anyone's guess. With this in mind, he came up with the following.
“我知道我什么时候在被嘲笑，”雌性说，“但这没关系。你病了，要死了。与此同时，我非常健康，牙齿好，对生活态度积极，所以如果这让你感觉好点，那就开玩笑吧。” 她刚刚露出了那种微笑，网状天花板分开了，一只人类的手出现了。起初它似乎是用蜡做的，那是它多么坚硬和不透明。但当它靠近并将她钉在地板上时，雌性闻到了橡胶的味道，明白了它戴着手套。然后是第二只手，这只手带着皮下注射针。当针尖沉入她的胃里，释放出疯狂的病毒冲击时，小白鼠靠在木屑上心想，他觉得大多数顺口溜都涉及一个地方。‘有一个来自得梅因的年轻鼹鼠，’说。或者‘在约克镇曾经住着一只雪貂。’他不知道他在哪里。这显然是一个实验室，但地点是谁的猜测。考虑到这一点，他想出了以下内容。
A she-rat I had as a roomy said illness just strikes if you're gloomy. Since she was injected with AIDS, I've detected an outlook a lot less perfumy. Funny, he thought, but it actually did make him feel better.
“我有一个室友是一只母鼠，她说如果你阴郁，疾病就会袭来。既然她被注射了艾滋病，我发现了一个不那么香的观点。” 很有趣，他想，但它确实让他感觉好多了。
David Sedaris. A story from his brand new book of animal fables, Squirrel Seeks Chipmunk. There's also an audiobook version. They both go on sale next week. [MUSIC - "BULLET WITH BUTTERFLY WINGS" BY SMASHING PUMPKINS] Well, our program was produced today by me and Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semein, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Production help from Sean Wen.
戴维·塞达里斯。来自他全新动物寓言书《松鼠寻找花栗鼠》的一个故事。还有有声书版本。它们都将在下周发售。[音乐 - Smashing Pumpkins的“BULLET WITH BUTTERFLY WINGS”] 嗯，我们的节目今天由我和乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布赖恩·里德、罗宾·塞梅因（Robyn Semein）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）提供音乐帮助。肖恩·温（Sean Wen）提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website: thisamericanlife.org, where you can sign up for our free weekly podcast. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International's WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. And perhaps you have you wondered, exactly how did Torey get a job in the high-stakes high-drama world of public radio management oversight?
我们的网站：thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以注册我们的免费每周播客。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台的WBEZ发行，对我们程序的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。也许你曾经想过，托里究竟是如何在公共广播管理监督这个高风险、高戏剧性的世界中找到工作的？
Because I'm smarter than the average person. 95% of the population doesn't have that common sense.
因为我比一般人聪明。95%的人口没有那种常识。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。